des ex is an accelerator an educational
program that's focused on design and the
built environment the program that
allows students to take what they are
creating here at MIT in studios and in
classes ideas they may have developed on
their own and to use those and develop
those while they're in school to launch
them into their professional careers or
to new businesses design X is looking
not first at the business but but really
have the problem and the design solution
for it students here don't shy away from
those and that's what I'm really excited
about is giving them the tools to
address those challenges
today we're Brady's and opportunities to
the masses to our members and this time
originate
once you're in the program there's a
business workshop and a full-on
accelerator student they work on their
ideas and turn them into marketing
products and processes you're receiving
mentorship from professionals from
business people from industry experts
the research that we do in design eyes
is immediately being fed back into the
educational lab partner finding gaps in
the existing organizational structure to
identify where should our new
organizations head in the direction
towards with our partners and Industry
there's gonna be a chance to take an
idea and actually deploy it to test it
in a real-life setting we have a two-way
flow of information to understand the
challenges from the real world and bring
those into design acts to take the
products and the solutions that were
developing here and push them out into
the world they're transforming cities
they are developing new approaches to
design
and ways for people to live this is a
school that is based on creativity and
interaction with communities and making
life better for people as a whole
Nations
[Music]